Oh my God.
You know what's crazy?
This is it.
[inaudible]
a viral New York Times article featured 36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people falling in love.
We want it to see what would happen if we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
Hi,
my name is Jaylene Dawkins and I'm single.
I've actually never been in a relationship.
Yes.
So I've been on dates,
but I've never had a boyfriend,
so I'm like low key single my whole life,
but I'm 21 so it's not crazy.
I think
my name is Mickey Miller and I am single as a Pringle.
Are you nervous?
You know,
more so than I thought I would a little bit,
but I'm good on dates this year.
I've given a lot of attention to myself and haven't really made myself
available,
but I think,
uh,
I think I'm good.
I think I'm ready.
Hmm.
Hello.
How are you?
Good.
Well,
what's your name?
Jaylee.
Mikey team.
Nice to meet.
Yeah,
it's like a long Hollywood suspended.
Well,
waiting for me or like,
yeah.
Do I grab a card?
Well I think the tea for two that warrants t I so,
oh it's really good team ready I bank.
Um,
if you could wake up tomorrow having gained one quality or ability,
what would it be?
Is it weird that I thought of a superpower first?
I would love to tell apart because I commute every day to school and then also I
really want to travel.
Something like that would just be amazing.
Yeah.
Are there limitations or teleporting parameters you have to stay with it?
Why put limits on teleportation?
Okay.
One Quality
I'll go sappy cause that's like kind of a savvy person.
Okay.
Um,
I think like having the utmost like empathy and having kind of like um,
unconditional positive regard for people and myself,
honestly,
take one minute and tell your partner your life story as much detail as
possible.
Jeez.
Grew up super silly jock.
Yeah.
It didn't really start questioning myself until I lost a lot of people in my
life really,
really quickly.
And they were all under the age of like 50.
I'm talking like seven people probably.
Yeah.
And then it wasn't until then that I started to really question things started
experimenting more moves here.
Life goes fast.
Is that a minute
you're like,
that's it.
That's last.
Yeah.
Here.
Um,
ever since I was a kid I wanted to have my own business.
I was kind of trying to figure out what that was when I was growing up.
First I wanted to be a chef and I was like,
yeah,
I was obsessed with Gordon Ramsay.
Still am one is restaurants really golden.
It's my favorite person ever.
All right.
And then I dunno,
I have,
I wanted to go into accounting,
which was completely different.
I wanted to have a good look at a dog daycare and then I was like,
you know what?
I really love fashion.
And then that was,
but this was like,
I figured that out when I was 10.
So then I'm like,
okay,
that's what I'm going for.
I'm super passionate about a lot of things.
Yeah.
I think that opens up the mind.
What is your most terrible memory growing up?
I was not close to my sister and then she had to get surgery.
I Dunno like when this happened when I was really young too,
so no one was telling me anything.
When you go home and someone who was there all the time because you're in close
quarters like myth thing because nobody wanted to let you know.
I mean,
yeah,
but a lot of a lot of things got up,
went wrong,
but luckily it went right.
No,
it was weird because I was like,
I hate my sister.
But then she was gone and I was like,
I kind of love my,
yeah,
terrible memory.
I mentioned I lost a whole bunch of people in a short amount of time.
The eerie thing is they were all like getting the phone calls about them.
They were all the same feeling where like my mom would call me.
It was always my mom and I would pick up and it's not thing that I had a feeling
before answering it,
but as soon as you like answer the phone,
you could feel her on the other line and then like every time it sucks.
I don't want to cry in front of everybody because it'd be weird.
But like you here,
my mom would be crying and it happened over and over and over.
In the span of a couple of years,
I have a tattoo from like my,
my best friend growing up,
she was basically my sister,
um,
and lost her in a car accident.
She was at a party not drinking and came home,
wasn't driving.
The person that was driving wasn't drinking and it was just like snowy
Pennsylvania,
dark roads,
her side hit a tree and we lost her.
Like even thinking about it,
you just like have that feeling and gut.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Um,
yeah,
that's gotta be the worst one.
All right,
let's see.
Okay,
complete this sentence.
I wish I had someone with whom I could share.
Oh my God.
You know what's crazy?
This is it.
Like,
I love tea and I'm not a coffee person and I'm like,
I literally finally,
they
love coffee more,
but I love tea.
I love tea.
And I'm like,
even if you don't like it,
you still have to be here and drink.
What would would,
what do I want to share
something with traveling for sure.
There's a huge part of me that wants to travel by myself,
but I think,
you know,
falling in love with somebody or whatever and then traveling and having that
experience,
I think those experiences are probably in comparable to anything else.
Yeah.
What is true love?
Wow.
Uh,
somebody that's like honest with you and that's not going to just tell you
whatever you want.
I'll never have a relationship that's like,
you know,
passive in any way and I'll never go in kind of thinking that I want you to make
me whole cause I think that's a mistake that a lot of people make.
They go into it thinking that they need when they want to fill a void.
Great.
I agree with that.
Um,
I was going to say like,
I was like,
it's kind of like friendships too.
Like I know a lot of people who weren't friends with the person that they're
with,
they just went straight into dating,
which I'm like,
how does that happen?
I would want to get to know the person as a friend or like a best friend and
everyone's like friends zone.
No,
but it's like if your partner is not your best friend,
like what are you doing?
You have to be able to go through all these things with someone to like grow and
like love them for who they are,
you know,
alternate sharing something you consider a positive characteristic of your
partner.
Share a total of three items.
Ooh,
okay,
good.
Migos.
Um,
your openness.
I'm not going to do
anything physical cause I feel like that's a cop out and it's already,
you know,
we already know,
uh,
but
super open,
which I admire.
The whole passion thing is really important.
Also admire what's a good three.
I'm sure really trying not to go physical and I guess it kind of up,
but you do have some nice smile.
I'll cut that.
Oh,
I'll tab off.
Yeah.
I'll take it though.
I'm going to steal yours.
I appreciate your openness.
I think that's so important.
You're like really like humble and you could talk about things that you,
what do you really want to talk to with a stranger,
you know?
Yeah.
That's not me.
I don't know if that's a good thing.
You're really funny like that's and that's awesome because it's nice to meet
someone with a sense of humor.
Yeah.
Last question.
You Ready?
Okay.
Yes.
These things.
What'd you go on a second date with your partner?
Ooh,
AH,
yeah.
Short and sweet.
I like it.
I appreciate it.
And we don't need a second date.
Just marriage,
right?
I guess.
Yeah.
See that's what I'm saying.
Riding the line between like what's funny and like the,
that was low Mike,
so I got,
no,
I should probably not do.
Then
we'll hold the hands and how to do this.
Hey guys,
Jason here.
Thank you so much for watching another episode of tea for two.
We hope you enjoyed.
We've been a really
exciting special announced.
If you are a Jew belief fan,
you love everything about jubilee.
We actually just set up a Facebook group for all of our super fans in case you
interested in learning more about what's happening behind the scenes,
seeing special things and just having a community.
You've talked to you about these episodes.
Please,
please sign up in the link below.
We're really excited to get to know you guys better and as always,
make sure you click the subscribe,
watch more videos,
and we'll see you next time.
Hello.